si l'objectif de vraiment beau et c'est
de venir à québec de manifester de
manière pacifique
une chose si son objectif c'est de venir
djamila ville de québec pour jamais la
ville de québec empêcher les
restaurateurs doivent de fonctionner les
petits commerçants moi je l'invite à
rester chic ça suscite une certaine
inquiétude
alors manifestez certes mais le faire
aussi en respect avec les gens et les
règles qui nous entoure on va être là
pour assurer leur sécurité par contre
doit-on tonight show qui va avoir des
désagréments ou des
10 entre havre liée à la présence de
rassemblement comme ça arrive dans toute
autre est simplement aussi je trouve
qu'on a droit de manifester c'est
correct que les gens c'est une soupape
les manifestations les gens veulent
s'exprimer on comprend que les gens sont
tannés tout ça et il ya moyen de le
faire convenablement dans le respect des
gens mais faisons attention c'est
préservons il faut respecter aussi les
autres petits ces gens le manifeste
contre les mesures sont tannés des
mesures sont tannés de l'aco vide mais
l'eau ici on a le carnaval qui commande
on a des familles des enfants qui vont
pouvoir enfin les jouer dehors dans une
belle activité organisée symbolique si
le carnaval à québec cet important avec
ce serait paradoxal d'embêter ou
d'empêcher les gens participent au
carnaval par une manifestation qui
serait débordante ou qui serait
irrespectueux
alors vous avez compris à la ville de
québec se prépare à l'arrivée de
manifestants anti mesures sanitaires
dans les prochains jours le maire nuit
hier mme confirmé l'émission son
intention de respecter le domaine
festive et quand même de bien se
préparer il autorise t donc veulent
préserver ce droit de manifester en
notant que cela se déroule dans le café
dans le respect alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire est ce que votre syrie ni
leçon d'ottawa ottawa toujours assiégés
depuis vendredi dernier par des
camionneurs très bruyant qui veulent
rester là longtemps
en fait y'a pas de plan pour les déloger
pour le moment et les manifestants
disent vouloir rester jusqu'à la levée
des mesures sanitaires et puis parlons
de l'alberta a coutume dans le sud de la
province les camionneurs qui bloquait un
poste frontalier avec les états unis ont
finalement été partiellement délogé par
la jirs sait mais la situation demeure
tendue tous ces événements soulève des
questions sur les limites au droit de
manifester jusqu'à le point avec louis
philippe lampron professeur à la faculté
de droit de l'université laval donc à
québec bonsoir monsieur le 1er mai 24 60
alors on veut se poser la question
justement avec l'idée que certains ont
devenir jamais québec est ce que des
limites acceptables au droit de
manifester il qu'en est il bayer
délimité tout départ du de la manière
qu'on va choisir pour exprimer son point
de vue le droit de manifester est une
activité qui protège et très clairement
la jurisprudence là dessus et constante
par la liberté d'expression qui est
protégé par la charte canadienne et la
charte québécoise maintenant une fois
qu'on a dit ça il ya quand même des
manières de manifester qui sont
carrément exclus de la protection
offerte par les chartes et ça ça va
dépendre essentiellement de ce type
d'activité qui va être en cause et du
lieu public où on va choisir de
manifester à large bande dans les
détails du test qui peut être un peu
soporifique les juridiquement par là
mais grosso modo l'exemple qui est le
plus souvent donnée par la cour suprême
du canada pour expliquer dans quelles
circonstances est ce que le choix de
s'exprimer d'une certaine manière
pourrait ne pas bénéficier de la
protection de la liberté d'expression
c'est justement l'idée de la barricade
alors on reçoit l'as tu veux libé de jam
et la ville de québec on parle de siège
et chez terreur alors c'est une chose
que de manifester qui vient
nécessairement avec des désagréments
c'est le coeur de la manifestation met
de la pression sur les élus maintenant
ça ne donne pas le droit que pas dans la
jurisprudence canadienne de faire
certaines choses comme par exemple kim
le pôle québec ou encore bloquer l'accès
à la colline parlementaire ça va
vraiment être intéressant de voir je
partage un peu les inquiétudes qui ont
été manifestées par les politiques vous
aviez au début du clip mais il ya des
choses qui ne sont carrément en
même temps vous vous êtes à québec vous
connaissez québec et un goulot
d'étranglement autour du parlement il ya
le carnaval monsieur turcotte du service
de police de québec disait ce matin en
point de presse la voie de circulation
du boulevard rené-lévesque vont rester
ouvertes ça c'est juste à côté du
parlement moi j'imagine tout cédé 0,18
rouleau stationner de londres ne
réveille que des résidents on ne le
bruit assourdissant d'ottawa
et on sent que les autorités ne veulent
pas faire une intervention
policière ou de d'évacuation on veut les
laisser manifester
alors écrit mots j'ai été étonné j'ai
agi comme observateur mois que nommé par
le gouvernement dans le cadre des
manifestations qui étaient attendus pour
le g7 est donc je suis heureux
d'apprendre que le spvq une grande
sensibilité pour le droit de manifester
mais c'est certain que cette réaction à
la je la salue le [ __ ] droit
fondamental se seront demande de nos
forces policières avant de laisser les
gens manifester mais dans un contexte il
ya quand même des annonces à
s'inquiétant qui sont faites par sookie
se sent bien à québec comme de jamy de
bloquer avec des camions l'eau à la
ville de québec c'est certain que moi je
suis je suis surpris en fait surtout
considérant l'ampleur comme moi du
dispositif policier auquel j'avais
insisté à l'époque juste et rappelez
vous il y avait finalement oui très peu
de manifestants et pourtant il ya eu
plusieurs centaines voire milliers de
policiers qui avaient encadré cette
manifestation c'est certain que c'est
assez étonnant maintenant à partir du
moment où on décide ya le droit yeux la
capacité de l'état être capable de faire
valoir ce droit là donc de déceler de
démontrer une manifestation même si elle
n'était pas protégée par la liberté
d'expression quand l île marge de
manoeuvre politique mais il ya quand
même la question de la realpolitik qui
va s'appliquer dans un convoi passe
quand je présente le temps d'écouter
l'extrait d'ottawa de monsieur trudeau
et de la police d'ottawa aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils se lancent la balle
politique et police on n'y prête pas à
un gouvernement et des politiciens de
donner des directions delà des commandes
à au service policier ils font leur
travail de façon indépendante
on voit se mettra en place ce grand
désert de véritables sièges durable est
ce que le premier ministre poser des
gestes pour lesquels les camionneurs
doivent bel et bien quitter et combien
de temps en temps tu il tolérer la
situation avant d'agir nous allons
continuer travailler avec les services
de loi et d'ordre avec les services
policiers pour s'assurer que les gens
sont protégés et que cette manifestation
qui commence à être illégal se termine
alors sans danger national ça me suis
trop d'expo ça va être une solution
policière puis la police on existe un
danger nationale et là on apprend que tu
avoir prouvé demandé l'assistance de
l'armée on veut pas de bain de sang l'on
peut on alors c'est quoi le jeune fille
à ce que des recours judiciaires c'est
que qu'est ce qu'on peut imaginer bas et
les recours judiciaires à un certain
moment à partir du moment où le
gouvernement affirme qu'il faut en
mettre à une manifestation jeudi
manifestants refusent de s'en aller mais
je n'y ai pas beaucoup d'autres
solutions que d'avoir recours à la force
policière à quelques pas aussi long de
choisir deux à brno droite
les choses et je pense que moi à ce qui
s'était passé a aucun il est toujours
une marge entre le droit puis la
capacité à précédant l'entrée dans le
réel que fondamentale maintenant
juridiquement parlant les désagréments
qui viennent avec les choix qui sont
faits par les manifestants dans le
cortège de manifestations par exemple
d'être bruyas de nuit que dans une
certaine mesure acceptée du canal de
québec ce n'est pas en soi suffisant ne
pas mettre fin de manifestation c'est
dans la nature de la manifestation là où
ça devient plus problématique c'est
quand on parle d' entrave durable qui
peuvent par exemple limiter de manière
durable importante au total l'accès aux
routes en fait pour être capable de
faire passer notamment les services
d'urgences l'on entre dans un an vous ce
choix là pourrait carrément être exclue
la protection offerte par la liberté
d'expression droit de manifester c'est
loin d'être évident même juridiquement
vraiment falloir voir comment est ce que
la manifestation se déploie à québec
mais au delà du jeu
politique très important c'est tout ça
est très délicate une grosse patate
chaude pour les gouvernements et les
forces de police merci à louviers plan
prend parfois plus
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh
[Musique]